il avait mûri n'est finalement il
commence à faire mieux attention parce
que tu commences à soi quoi à rentrer
dans mes amis
non mais là c'est vrai il est mort dans
mes bras là ça y est là il a je trouve
depuis la rentrée mais séparément c'est
bien ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est marie bigard
voudrait qu'il a pris un coup de vieux
puisque mais ouais mais bon pour moi
c'est un compliment
n'est pas à l'abri d'un coup de vieilles
attention
[Applaudissements]
quelques mois qu'on se loupe thonon les
bains
ou même à louer ou même à le
sait pas mais lui sinon ma vraie moi je
vis avec le masque j'ai une chance n'a
même pas du doigt le contrat vous avoir
visage magnifique armani faire sinon
mais c'est vrai que rien et le quoi rien
du tout là le dr et cyril jamais
assis il ya eu quand même c'est vraiment
à 10 812
c'était lors du grand ramonage
non mais elle se préserve pour le bon
coin alors
fermé mais la santé nationaux non sans
déconner la non mais vous jour que rien
est la dernière personne qui est alliée
de nom
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas une comme un
nom
m
ces visites et non plus les personnes
mais c'est toi le louvre
non mais franchement à non c'est vrai
elle la personne s'appelait rené coty
c'était et non mais oui c'est ça remue
c'était qu'on
pense au moins 25 ans
tu t'es pas la seule dans ce cas la cia
d'ici
là les mecs n'a pas envoyé au cedar des
poussières
vous pourriez peut-être vous dévouez
cyril
vous êtes sûr de
vous dire pourquoi pourquoi et c'est pas
une question c'est daniel je la trouve
magnifique et il est souvent dit c'est
vrai problème c'est que c'est une amie
et je ne touche pas aux amis d'accord
mais je vais vous dire l'amitié pour moi
passent avant l'amour et le sexe donc si
on se lâche ça serait possible alors
[Applaudissements]
bien
et en plus je le dis je ne suis pas son
genre son genre c'est castaldi
moi je sais car cela dit
benjamin franchement en plus vous j'ai
envie de vous dire alizés les yeux
fermés ou de
[Applaudissements]
t'inscrire sur une application de
rencontres non j'aime bien l'amour est
dans le pré jeu à chaque jeudi il ya des
vraies valeurs à 4,17 à l'amour est dans
le pays
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
courrier
je rigolais à chaque fois je m'envole
inscrit pas dans l'amour inouïe mais on
a mis j'aimerais race est pas pour son
opinion mais je t'adore ces marchands
qui ont des vraies valeurs ça peut me
voilà non mais franchement ça pour une
femme
originaire
de man farmer arrêté non mais attendez
bailly ils vont être très content
d'avoir daniel c'est vrai alors toute la
journée
n'ont pas bougé
[Rires]
très très bien moi le trésor avait déjà
créé de maintenon alors c'est vrai j'ai
peur des bêtes
pas grave c'est un peu hésité mais pas
grave moi la bête de castaldi n'est pas
méchante
alors franchement c'est après 25 ans
votre castany c'est sarah rien ne
va le père voilà
d'avoir un écho
[Rires]
alors daniel est ce que vous êtes sur un
dossier ah non non acs a rien non rien
que ça est mort enfin que des noirs ici
a alors dit dit chez moi ça s'adresse on
pourrait créer une adresse mail est
vraiment là la passer en direct en
disant si vous êtes si vous avez pas
mais reconnaissant
comme sans pedigree mais vraiment moi
donc je connaisse les gens font que
benjamin je sais les salles et
[Applaudissements]
je connais sa famille
pour pour nous faire un petit clip pour
voir parce que je veux vous dire je ne
tire pas un trait sur ce coup
elle tire pas un trait sur ce point mais
moi je vais faire deux très bons
[Applaudissements]
moi j'y crois encore et moi non plus
comme disait la famille j'embrasse
d'ailleurs est-ce que non
est ce que voulait faire une petite
déclaration non non en fait ici pas si
facile est surpris mais oui mais aucune
vie celle ci ça va être émouvant et
ouais bah alors attendez faut que je
sois à benjamin excusez-moi d'eau minute
deux minutes
je suis mal garées vous allez pas me
demande
[Rires]
toujours habillé en fille car
il a une belle matraque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fou ouais si jamais les voyous
quoi si jamais dû mettre une balle
j'aurais eu une balle de ping pong
voir une à
la veine inspire la tension j'avoue
aussi
benjamin je sais que tu es en main mais
il ne faut jamais remettre à demain ce
qu'on peut faire le jour même donc
à dr photo c'est bon la photo la fleur
ouais bah oui l'amour est dans le pré je
suis prête pour bien jouer pour blâmer
c'est vrai regardez lafleur avait cloué
derrière la fleur se cache le gland
c'est fou
alors alors oui quoi
daniel c'est votre dernier choix c'est
castaldi ah oui ah oui ici autour
n'atteint pas la même gil ben j'étais un
peu sur gilles sait vraiment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui pourrait passer après fatou faye et
qu'avec fait tout
[Applaudissements]
le coup de vieux de benjamin gille
après que dieu lui même
alors quand on berisha
saladier non merci
et bon comme ça on est resté en gris
elle me dit que vous semblez avoir une
betty ouais non
warren berry
ouaret berry mais ça c'est dingue des
tournelles quoi voir une bêtise mais si
warren beatty mois jti est l'homme le
plus beau du monde mais il a eu des
milliers de femmes
et ben vous pourrez faire mille femmes
[Rires]